[Music]
I'm the one
all right home team episode number 247 a
lot of things has happened the last
24 hours even the last 12 hours a lot of
uh new things formulating to give an
update on what's going on with the
market the economy uh Goldman says Sac
says they're no longer expecting the FED
to hike rates in March that's a CNBC
story Bloomberg came out with another
story saying fed's battle plan for
inflation shredded by Financial turmoil
Jeffrey gunlock who's been on
valuetainment before with Daniel
demartino Booth says fed will hike funds
next week to save credibility will have
to interesting uh musk is building a
Tiny Village for his workers South
Korean government proposes increase
in work week to 69 hours from 52 hours
I'm sure California lost their mind
remote remote work in is killing Florida
as a retirement Paradise that is an
Insider story I have a video of uh
president Trump saying a few words about
Ron DeSantis and Florida which I I found
interesting uh Ron DeSantis published
with a handmade snoke snowflake it had
the word fascists written all over it
again Insider story a bunch of different
things uh but first things first Tom
last 24 hours with all this Silicon
Valley Bank debacle that everybody's
talking about what's new what's been
building up what are you seeing well
well good morning
um I think everybody heard there was a
soft Landing because the federal
government has this facility in place to
protect the depositors what was really
interesting is the stories came out that
showed what unfolded behind the scenes
and apparently
um you know you talked about it
yesterday you know Jamie Diamond it was
a banker and a tough entrepreneur and
you look underneath the covers remember
his folks were rumored to have been
working all-nighters on Thursday to
Friday Friday to Saturday and a
Bloomberg story this morning came out
bright and early with the European
markets apparently JP Morgan got a
couple billion dollars of new deposits
as a result of this uh reaching out
saying hey you need a bank JP Morton's
here to help you and it's 3 A.M you're
up we're up we got you covered and so
that happened and then the big four
Banks apparently circled around like
sharks on a Feeding Frenzy were picking
up scraps it was said that both City and
B of A were in there but not nearly at
the level of the JP Morgan was and then
the other thing that came out this
morning now that the FED has a little
Breathing Room remember they were trying
to get the sale done by Sunday so that
before the European markets open they
could say everything's cool we got uh
svb was sold to somebody that was the
plan now they get a little breathing
space and apparently
BlackRock and Apollo have both walked
into the buffet table and said you know
what
um I'd like the loan book so I think it
works out better for everybody if a bank
buys svb but you've got big private
Equity firms coming up there now saying
hey
um you know what we're interested in the
loan book and what this points out pbd
is this is we hope means we don't have
to use any of the federal money that
Janet Ellen was talking about at that
what works out is that the bank is sold
and the depositors are made hold on
those sales so that it I think that's
the best for the economy and best for
the bank let me let me ask that's what's
been happening so let me ask a question
here Tom so if a lot of the conversation
is what do we learn from 2008 right to
not do the same or to do better right so
if if right now a 2008 were to happen
would the feds have bailed out AIG
now the numbers now are so big I think
they would have had to at the end of the
day or been forced to but you know I
don't know after printing 1.4 trillion
and seeing what that did to the economy
and the inflation of assets I think it
would have been hard I think it would
have been much harder but a lot of
political pressure would have been on it
we got to do this and tarp 7 would have
had to have been implemented
um but I think it would have been a
really tough call because especially
with what all this money we just printed
and the inflation we caused so so if
they would have if they would have taken
the same approach as they're taking with
Silicon Valley Bank in 08 that's what I
want to know what do you think would
happen so AIG is going out of business
we're not going to bail them out uh you
know yesterday I put the four economic
uh you know yeah I love that by the way
the freedom to buy freedom to sell
freedom to try for them to fail yeah and
and I posted that a guy came up who knew
I sold a lot of AIG we were the number
one IO writer at AIT for many years and
he says would you have said the same
thing
if AIG was uh you know in the situation
would you build that edge I said no the
previous CEO made bad decisions
uh forcing the former CEO of MetLife to
come out of retirement who had only
three years left to live to drive the
company Bob Ben moshe's leadership is
what saved AIG but this was the part
about capitalism and today would they
have left AIG to go belly up and had
other people come and acquire this
business that I'll buy this business
I'll buy that business I'll buy the PNC
business I'll buy your however many
planes that AIG had you think that would
have happened today I think that's
probably the way you would have had to
do it today and we have to remember
there's a key difference between OA and
what happened yesterday yesterday who
got protected the depositors and they
openly said the shareholders and most of
the bondholders are screwed when I say
most of the bondholders the most senior
bondholders there may be some assets to
give them but the bottom level
bondholders and all the shareholders you
are wiped out back then remember Lehman
and bear went down but the rest of the
banks were saved last time they saved
the banks this time they've saved the
depositors last time they saved the Auto
industry the companies and only Alan
malali went in front of Congress and
said we'll take a loan but we don't want
to Grant Ford will be fine remember it
was the companies that were saved last
time the positors received it that's
good so we're learning we're learning
what not to do and by the way I think
that's positive the the the the the the
comment about the fact that taxpayers
are not going to pay this that's
[__] I mean they're we're still
paying for that there's no question
about that can you while I'm while
you're getting the video prepared Adam
you have some thoughts go ahead but uh
go to my Twitter account with the video
but go ahead yeah I was just I was just
going to bring up the the Lehman
Brothers and the the bear Stearns
example because when I entered the
financial industry was 06 I got into the
life insurance life settlement game and
I knew nothing about nothing I was a
nightlife guy and I got you know into
this new career but we were doing
business with Lehman Brothers and bear
Stearns at that time and I had a buddy
that worked for Layman and it was so
interesting how the conversations were
going where it's like we're working on
these deals and putting together they're
putting together a life settlement fund
and all that and all of a sudden he's
like yep I think we're gonna be holding
off for a while yep I don't know if I
have a job anymore yep I just got fired
yet my Bank closed and to see we talked
about picking winners and losers and
this whole the whole concept and this is
what I wanted to kind of revisit what
you said and I love the fact that you
kind of just simplify what capitalism
stands for the freedom to to buy to sell
to try to fail
and I think it's I think it's incumbent
to understand the failure part is part
of the process and the whole you know
how they say in the government we don't
want the government picking winners and
losers and you know chamoth came out
right
um during covid when he and this is
after like the stock BuyBacks that were
happening all that and in 19 and all
that after um that whole situation he
goes let them fail let the airlines fail
so that there needs to be ramifications
for poor decisions so how do they just
think like how did they distinguish to
let AIG to to allow them to stay but
Layman and bear Stearns like who's
picking these situations at the end of
the day
this whole too big to fail concept
it's sort of the antithesis of what
capitalism is right like if you screw up
you make poor decisions like if an
individual does this and they spend all
their money they max out credit card
debt they they go on vacation when they
should be just saving money and they
lose their job and they fail then it's
kind of expected but when companies do
that why should they receive these
bailouts hey Pat and I'm honestly I'm
not setting up a question here I'm
trying to remember and I don't remember
but remember the sifi test s-i-f-i and
we had some life insurance carriers that
didn't want that designation because it
came with a lot of government kind of
being in your knickers remember that and
I think I'm trying to remember was it
the gentleman we know at um AIG who has
since retired who said that when you get
named strategically was it strategically
important financial institution siffy
that soon as you were named that yeah
systematically important financial
institution that it was actually a bad
thing so now the government was on your
back you have to have by the way you
have to have double reserves there hey
your loan loan balance is the tenth of a
point too high and suddenly it's like
wait a minute I'm no longer I'm not
being Reckless I'm no longer even
running my business I got this this uh
Overlord pushing me can I ask you a
question on that so this the overload
concept so the whole concept of
Regulation over regulation under
regulation you know Trump came out and
said
you know so these these uh medium-sized
uh local banks Regional Banks they're
going to bump them up to what 50 million
to 250 250 billion billion 50 billion up
to 250 billion to kind of let the
regulation uh less regulation do what it
do where does this kind of fall under
the siffy thing so is that well read the
federal yeah that's what I was saying
the U.S federal Regulators determine
would pose a serious risk to the economy
if it were to collapse so this is the
siffy thing so so who's determining yeah
those so so why don't you type in sifi
list type in sifi list siffy list yeah
there you go 2022 okay there you go so
uh Allianz AIG aegon yeah aegon uh
where was that list
um go back there's got to be an easier
way to go let's just read some of those
right there Allianz AIG aegon two out of
the three matter of fact three out of
three we've done business but Aviva yeah
true all of them so massive carriers not
even necessarily financial institutions
right yep but but if you think about it
how often do you hear life insurance
companies going out of business you
don't no you hear Banks going out of
business why is that because the bank's
dollar to reserve ratio you know
whatever they lend out isn't as high uh
as the life insurance life insurance
companies like at one point do you
remember you and I flew out to our monk
with our old uh French uh friend Amor
and we went to right across the street
from uh uh IBM and we had a meeting with
credit with Swiss tree right yep and I
was just going to bring up the
reinsurance yeah exactly this small
humble building any artwork
you [__] there's like multi-million
dollar art in the lobby please tell me
this was the trip that Tom and Amor room
together no no that was way before but I
don't know no I had recovered yeah so so
uh so we had a friend who liked to walk
around uh naked and I I try to make the
intro of Tom and him I said listen I
think you guys gotta warm up to get
closer at c-suite and they did and the
next I said how was how was it he says
well listen I had no clue this guy like
so hot well now you guys know each other
anyways but when we went there if you
remember this conversation we wanted to
start an insurance company and you know
we wanted to see is it better for us to
go out there and compete with a as a
carrier and what that responsibility was
how much of the risk that we have to
take Etc et cetera versus just selling
it instead of you know running an
insurance company let me tell you it is
practically impossible to start your own
insurance company today with a hundred
percent of you know you you the dollar
amount the savings you need to have it
it's the liability the responsibility of
it was massive so I understand what
they're doing from the insurance I
actually like it because this is why you
don't see that many insurance companies
going out of business but you know
you're talking about all this stuff with
FDIC can you pull up the Tweet the video
I just posted this is the president of
Minneapolis Bank uh Federal Reserve uh
uh uh listen to what he says to 60
minutes this is March of 2020. think
about the time March of 2020 covet is
just getting started look what he says
so we're about to have the Covenant yeah
get spiked out watch this
to the person who is about to grab their
car keys and go to the ATM and take out
three thousand dollars you say what you
don't need to your ATM is safe your
banks are safe there's enough cash in
the financial system and there is an
infinite amount of cash that the Federal
Reserve we will do whatever we need to
do to make sure that there's enough cash
in the banking system
okay infinite infinite so that's exactly
the problem the problem is infinite how
where does that money come from so you
know you know how sometimes people you
know when you look at O.J Simpson and
what do people say you remember when OJ
was whatever the year was 93 94 now I
don't remember you but something like
that right the year with the trial with
the trial yeah yeah it could have been
92. it was uh yeah 93 I want to say okay
94. so what was the thought oh well you
know what he's not going to go to jail
you know he's not going to because
celebrities never again they get away
with everything what happened this guy's
walking around and 99 of people and I
don't even want to say 99 the majority
of people you talk to there's a survey
did he kill the answer is what yes and
he's free the one question he doesn't
like to answer you know what the
question is when people ask him they try
to be sarcastic with them did you find
the killer you said you were going to
walk around yeah guys how do you feel
about it he's still out there yeah we
gotta find it and you'll see the first
thing he does is he moves his eyes he
doesn't looking this is like I really
don't want to talk about that yeah
because you're in the room right okay so
unless unless uh Sasha Baron Cohen is
interviewing him then again yeah so so
the frustration with that the
frustration with celebrities getting
away with things that they do is the
same frustration with companies that get
away with anything because then there is
no discipline and repercussion it's
necessary to have repercussion and a
price from making bad mistakes there is
nothing wrong with it I failed a lot
here's the part you know what's the
unique thing about failing very simple a
philosopher many years ago said this it
sucks okay there is no way to put it it
sucks it's embarrassing it could lead to
a divorce it could lead to mental
anguish emotional heartache it can go
through it's challenging times you're
gonna go through it nothing about it is
going to feel good trust me think about
it this way what happens in box when two
people fight and one gets knocked out
publicly humiliated in front of tens of
millions of people think about the text
messages think about how many exes
celebrate that loss think about how many
friends from high school are like man
I'm so glad he got his ass whooped that
felt great think about how it felt for
Wilder to lose to Tyson Fury Three Times
back to back to back and he was called
the bomber like think about how it felt
when Tyson lost to you know Buster
Douglas nobody thought that was going to
happen every one of everybody's gonna go
through it there's enough when Foreman
lost to Ali he went into depression for
a couple years he didn't want to show
his face because nobody believed the
fact that he lost to Ali that was not
supposed to happen it's supposed to hurt
and it also hurts in business there was
a period in my career where I went
through really tough times emotionally
running a company
here's here's the thing about the
seasons like that it's not supposed to
feel good it you know you're supposed
You're Gonna Be Lonely you're you're
gonna try to like last night a weird
night last night I I slept on the floor
last night one of our kids wasn't doing
too well he was throwing up all night it
just wasn't a good situation I'm on one
hour of sleep today you know who cares
nobody trust me nobody cares nobody
cares I still have to come and do my job
today no one cares no one in the
audience cares not saying that you're
not sympathetic but it's not your
problem it's my problem okay I still
have to come in and do this I gotta Zoom
right after this and I got a bunch of
today's a long day for me I got a lot of
stuff that's going on here today no one
cares it's days like this that you gotta
show up even though nothing is going
your way so the fact that the Silicon
Valley the shareholders are paying a
price for it it hurts but it happens in
business the fact that some of the
bondholders are not getting the money
back it hurts but that's part of
business can I say one thing about the
the failure part
um I think you're absolutely right I
think failure is a part of life and uh I
would argue that
I think any one of us would would say
that sometimes failure is the best thing
that can possibly happen to because it
it sort of makes you who you are so
whether it's been sports for me I
remember being a great athlete and then
getting moved up to Varsity and then
been put on the bench oh [__] I gotta
improve when I did stand-up comedy I was
always a funny dude I got booed off
stage talk about like tomatoes to the
face it's like oh my God I actually have
to get better at this relationships
we've all had relationships that we
failed at but you learn from these
situations I used to do cold calls for a
living for years and getting hung up on
and hung up on and hung up on but that's
what makes you stronger and you you
bring up the the George Foreman
situation it's funny to see the the end
of that narrative it's like he ended up
becoming a
multi-multi-millionaire do the Foreman
Grill because he got back in the ring
and he started kicking some ass again
and I think that's what everyone needs
to understand is that failure is going
to come with the territory if you want
to be great at anything you're going to
fail but what's the old saying you know
fall 10 times get up 11 and that's what
it comes down to yeah look I got two
videos higher or you can get up yep I
got I got a couple videos I want to show
you and I got a book here I want to show
you which I saw this I ordered this my
assistant came in saying someone's
playing a prank on you uh and they sent
you this book I said no I bought this
book so I just kind of wanted to show it
today because Tom don't look at it I
want to see what the reaction is going
to be to this book I'm getting her but
let me let me first go to uh our uh
sponsor here or a quick shout out to
them at this point of the game look if
if you're not protecting yourself
everything in life there's offense
there's defense you make investments to
make money you go out there in the sales
business to make money you start a
business to make money you could take
courses to improve you do all of that
stuff to win in advance that's offense
defense you buy auto insurance you buy
life insurance you buy you know all
these different types of insurances this
is one of those insurance policies that
you need to have all in one digital
safety for the whole family protect from
identity theft fraud and online threats
you can go on there with aura and find
out how many times your passport are
being used on the dark web just go out
there and test it we've done this many
times we've talked about this many times
we have people that have 30 times 40
times their past and they're like you
got to be kidding me my passwords out
there yep they have access to it so this
is another form of protecting yourself
if you haven't yet it's free 14 days up
to 42 percent
of savings protect you and yourself from
America's fastest growing crime try Aura
free for two weeks and see if any of
your or your family's personal
information has been compromised start
your 14-day trial at aura.com forward
slash pbd once again aura.com forward
slash pbd the link will be below for you
to go to okay this book the other day
um you know I like books for kids and
there's a lot of different kinds of
books and then this book pops up and I
said this has to be a joke no it's a
real book What's the title of the book
that's the title of the book if you can
zoom in the game if you can zoom in by
the way Rob you're laughing and you know
part of it could be funny the the
website is called queerbooks.com okay
and this is a real book so I bought it
I'm like okay let me take a look at this
the gay BCS let's go through it together
oh sorry about that well well let's take
a look so here's what a a is4 is that
Ally a friend who is there to stand up
for you with strength loving care I like
that yeah uh B is for bye you can shout
it out loud I like boys and girls and
that makes me proud
what ages is this for does it say it
again I mean what ages it's like you're
not getting this at 18 years old this is
a kid's book this this has got to be the
author is M.L Webb who actually want to
go through this to see on Amazon it says
the grade level is preschool through
third grade yeah this is exactly where I
was going with the priest okay don't say
gay Bill specifically targets people
third grade and under do not talk about
that so basically Congressman C is for
coming out you're ready to share what
you feel deep inside it's okay to be
scared D is for drag
you construct and by the way this is not
a joke this is a book you can strut and
dance in clothes that you have dresses
heels and pants
e is for equality we're on the same team
we all have the right to love hope and
dream
F is for family related or found they'll
stick to by your side ups and down good
G is for gay it's a word that implies
that you're a girl who likes girls or a
guy who likes guys H is for Hope dream
up a life you love sky's the limit and
by the way intersexes I J is for Joy key
is for Kiki uh uh L is for lesbian M is
for Mountain uh n is for non-binary OS
for orientation P is for pan Q is for
obviously queer R is for respect
s is for Sashay sachet sachet
the guys with drag T is for shout out to
Rupaul there T is for Trans it's a brave
step to take to live as the gender you
know uh U is for Unique V is for Vogue W
is for Wonder X is four you can write it
down when you have ammo from his pronoun
U is for you uh wise for you Z assessed
yeah that's a book okay the ABCs okay so
should they have the right to sell this
book the answer is what of course yes of
course you should have the right to sell
this book price of free speech is Free
Speech yeah there's there's nothing
wrong with by the way this came out in
2019 this is before the the series yeah
this transculture Wars really really
were highlighted but but now here's the
part you you when they say nobody is
grooming yeah that's the part when you
see stuff like this as a parent this
stuff is you know getting into schools
this stuff is getting into kids reading
this what is a five-year-old think about
when they read something like this the
eight-year-old a ten-year-old if if if
you like if if I were to tell you right
now as a kid what phrase do you remember
your mother or your father telling you
that you believe till today positive
what phrase what did your mom or dad
tell you that till today you remember my
mom would always tell me you can be
anything you want to be just as long as
you're give it your best okay Tom my
parents are big on um honesty okay
always tell me the truth even if you've
done something tell me the truth how
many how many times did they say that to
you how many times did they say it was
it was constant it was it was constant
my brother and I were only about uh less
than two years apart we would get into
Mischief things would happen I remember
six seven years old we'd break something
and so it was always or somebody gets
hurt Somebody's Crying and it's like
tell us the truth tell me the truth and
I can remember the punishment was always
slightly moderated if you told the truth
if they had to dig it out of us or one
of us was lying it was always the
punishment was a little heavy at the
belt for what no for what you did
or for and for the lie it was like a
compounding effect but if we told the
truth but that was always what my
parents say just tell me the truth what
was it what what was it that was over
and over again for you Rob what was it
for you over and over like you heard
over and over again
I I don't even know why to this day but
it just sticks in my head my dad used to
say no matter where you go there you are
I have no idea what that means I if
you're lost you're somewhere that's a
quote from Buckaroo Banzai I thought
that was Austin Powers hey there you are
do I know you no but there you are Adam
how about yourself my mom I mean again
she always told me to try us but my mom
is like the the most loving caring
person she would always say
um
I don't care who it is it could be the
CEO or the janitor you have to treat
them the same like you have to treat
people the same way you have to do this
you have to treat people right treat
people right treat people do you want to
be treated the Golden Rule treat people
right treat people right and that served
me okay so here's here's a question for
you I want to flip it on you you ready
some of you already know where I'm going
with this what if Adam your mom said
Adam if you're gay it's okay
what if your mom said Adam if you're
like boys it's okay what if you're
actually on what you think about Adam if
you're gay just tell me yeah what if she
told you that a thousand times over and
over and over again now you may say I
would still be straight because I love
women right but let me tell you
something that's a thousand times that
thought is in your head as a
six-year-old eight-year-old ten-year-old
confirmation if your mom and dad told
you Tom
if you like boys you can tell me son
like can you imagine even that phrase
like preemptively before you even said
instantly even the kid given a sign like
they're saying anything like here's a
question what is the advantage of a kid
reading this book
what is the advantage of kid reading
this book that's what I want to know
what is the advantage if somebody is
in a climate like this of where we are
today you think people feel
uncomfortable being gay today versus
what it was 30 years ago no like so so
this is the part where you get a Bill
Maher that comes out saying why are you
trying to
so there's a video I'm going to send it
to you a a Rob if you can share this
where a child exposes uh his mom okay
it's a very I don't know if you guys
have seen this video or not where there
are parents now where they're proud to
have this and talk about this and say
look my kids are gay it's a bragging
right
if the the Asian father says you know my
son said did we play this clip before or
no I want to show this to you as well
Rob if you can see this clip I just sent
to you look how the kid is like and the
mom gets a little bit upset just look at
this reaction I think this is the same
video
volume yeah let's see if this is the one
or not watch this
people that aren't like serial killers
like Ted does your mom say you have to
be LGBT no I think she's what I want to
be but some but
God that's fine keep talking say what's
your son
my mom doesn't matter if I'm up if I am
gay or a lesbian or any of that she
doesn't care all she cares about is that
I'm a part of it
and if I'm not a part of it she'll try
to convince me to
um get join it because I what are you
sorry though
facts that I would convince you to join
what tells you with the qia Plus
that's crazy
you saw the mom's reaction a kid is not
going to say something like that just
because he thinks about that even a kid
is sitting there saying dude my mom just
wants to be a part of this organization
right there's a problem here there's
this there's this parent I don't know if
you've seen this one uh uh um
let me let me see this one if I can find
you have to see this one uh it's it's
I'll find a clip to show it to you but
you see a book like this you see what
happens it gives credibility to parents
Tom what are your thoughts when you see
something like this
look the price of free speech is Free
Speech that's my first thought and my
second second thought is each
organization each group is going to
publish books that it wants to read and
lgbtq they're going to publish books
they want to read and books for their
kids and that's that's the long and
short of it
um I feel you know
to kind of it exposes the feeling his
mom is telling him one thing but he's
feeling a different thing and there's
some conflict in that kid but but just
thinking about even giving your thoughts
on it do you feel uncomfortable
well yeah because you know nowadays
um you know I I am the unprotected enemy
a you know white male Canadian descent
though may I be you know I'm you know if
I say anything too much I will catch the
most heat so I never moderate or lie
about my positions but I'm very careful
about expressing them
just say one thing that you know
um a you know to use the alphabet
analogy there's nothing wrong with being
gay and let before we go down this
Rabbit Hole of like these guys are
anti-gay it's if that's who you are as
an adult God bless you we have gay
friends lesbian friends all good like
very vocal I go out in South Beach I
know all they're all out there the
Roberts decision says you can marry do
what you got to do but I think the the
resounding uh effort from from at least
our narrative is like leave the goddamn
kids alone with this kind of stuff
specifically the fact that Rob pointed
out that this book is aimed at third
grade and under
so what is that eight years and under so
what are you talking five six seven
eight-year-olds why is sex and and
gender and identity and all this even a
thing at this age now we can have the
argument or conversation of when do you
start teaching these kind of things is
it is it Middle School is it high school
is it do the kids talk amongst
themselves or should it be a clash
should it be booked should it be the
free market but I think we're all in
agreement that kindergarteners should
not be figuring it out if they're bi or
not that's not a thing that they should
be uh developing at that age like for
instance when I was in kindergarten I
wanted to be a dinosaur okay so if
someone was like it's okay to be a
Tyrannosaurus Rex that's who you are on
the inside it's like okay at what point
is does it go to all right I want to be
Peter Pan I want to be a cowboy in India
and I want to be an athlete I want to be
a princess when does reality and fantasy
kind of take over especially when you're
a kid because you have wild imaginations
and I think it's just it just leave the
kids alone uh play this clip play this
is the problem though this is the
problem right here play this clip uh are
here today because we have a trans trans
child actually six years old at three
she was not sleeping very well she was
waking up every single night it was a
lot more than just a toddler waking up
and one day I picked her up from daycare
all the teachers had said
Asher told us that she's a chi and
Ashford comes around the corner and I
said hey there's my beautiful daughter
what oh a few sleepless nights
became positive Matt does a great job
talking about the stuff
your son did you hear like this guy
sounds like an educated guy three years
old what are you talking about bro and
and he's getting the mic
the mic
he's get you know what you know what is
a form of giving to Mike to speak at an
event that is a recognition if somebody
gives you Their audience
they're Mike that is a form of a
recognition I recognize you that you
have a credible message to give come
give your message we're giving the mic
to that message that father can believe
that
but if he's doing that because he wants
to be invited to certain parties or he
wants to be accepted by a certain
Community or he wants to be known as a
sensible you know whatever whatever but
then you're using your kid as a prop
like you know how uh uh uh the joke
about uncles are like hey let me let me
borrow your two-year-old Kidman to go to
the mall and say you take the kid and
like hey oh you have such a beautiful oh
thank you oh so what's your name is oh
my God you said do that with puppies
yeah you do with cats though we deal
with cats so so so but you know it's
kind of like a prop that you use you're
using your kid as a prop for some like
this give it a break you know who's
going uh who's training right now on
Twitter Drew Barrymore you know why
she's training right now on Twitter
because of this Tick Tock guy Dylan
Mulvaney I don't know if you've seen
what happened with this Dylan Mulvaney
uh where a bunch of people are posting
this you know sharing how you know uh uh
her story of uh trance and all this
stuff and then eventually Drew Barrymore
apparently get on gets on her knees I
don't know if you've seen this or not
that's the picture that's going viral uh
uh uh right there that's the knee
picture so she gets on her knees that's
a guy
that's that guy in the dress that yeah
Drew's definitely not a guy but the guy
that that's a guy that is a and why she
underneath what's going on it's like man
thank you so much for being so brave and
doing this this is what we're
highlighting that this is what's being
turned into Heroes okay that is the
problem you know the the the and and by
the way the same exact when I watched
Tom being uncomfortable with this
you know what the average parent is
thinking about right now here's what the
average parent's thinking about right
now
Tom and I were talking yesterday we're
talking about a couple big deals that
we're doing and we're in my room
upstairs and I'm getting Tom's Council
like I always do I'm always asking Tom
hey Tom what do you think about this
time what do you think about them we're
processing issues together
and
one of the deals that we're going
through Tom says I worry if we're going
to be able to close that deal
I said why is that and if it happens
you'll hear about it it's very big if it
doesn't happen you'll never hear about
it maybe I'll write about it in a book
five years from now 10 years from now
but you're not going to hear about it
anytime soon
and he says I worry if that deal is
going to close
I said tell me why he says because of
the opinions and the stuff we talk about
I worry if that Community will accept
the voice and what we talk about on the
podcast
you know what that is you that fear
shouldn't exist
when you have kids like here's the part
with me as a parent so I'll go to
schools okay
and I'll go to the school and I'll see
some of the parents and you'll talk to
some of the parents or you'll see some
of the teachers and some of them will
fully you'll know if they're with you
and they'll say oh my God hey what's up
Patrick how you doing oh my God that's
so great the last podcast this I loved
it and then you'll also see some of them
that are kind of like I know who you are
I can't stand what you stand for totally
cool but now watch this
as this gets bigger
what's going to happen to their last
name it's not like their last name is
Aguilar or Jones or Jackson where
there's a billion you know not a billion
but there's a lot of aguilars Jones and
Jackson's out there right the last name
is what but David how many sauce links
are there how many else words have you
met in your life okay but the point I'm
trying to make too is there that fear
shouldn't be there as a kid when I lived
in Iran and people would ask me about my
religion and my parents would say don't
say it never liked it like my parents
are Christians we're Christians I never
liked the fear where you can't talk
about it because you're going to be
judged you know yesterday I posted a job
post and we're hiring right now
aggressive we've got 18 job openings and
I posted a video if you can go to the
video I posted yesterday one of the
guy's comments and he says something and
uh we got hundreds of applications being
submitted last night this guy says
something I hope the comment comes all
the way at the top so I can read this
comment because this this is kind of
where we need to go where keep going
keep going keep going it's a video right
there go to the comment click on it and
let's go to the comment section go the
lower go look okay right there fantastic
it's there zoom in he says Patrick so
I'm asking for somebody to be our
managing director of our consulting firm
right by David Consulting and I said to
be able to be the managing director with
David Consulting this is a multi-multi
six-figure job that's going to pay very
well to whoever it's going to be okay
with the potentially making seven
figures within a three to a five year
period it's a high paying job
this guy says Patrick I don't like your
criteria when you start a PHP you
weren't an ex McKenzie consultant but
you still had the chops to do the job
well and you did it
there's talented folks out there who
don't care about your prestige you're
overlooking by bias for MD okay this is
not an easy job for an average guy off
the streets to come and do and by the
way when I was starting PHP I was a 30
year old running a multi-million dollar
year business in my 20s I wasn't just
the guy off the street look at my
response what I said to him on the
bottom I said my criterias were never
intended to be liked it's not for
everyone all the best yeah you know what
I like its response
fair I respect it good luck with the
search actually like is the way he
handled it as well yeah I I I my goal
with with this podcast and where we're
going and what the climate is for us to
be able to say
this Dylan Mulvaney Guy this is weird
stuff what you're doing that this is a
weird book
it's weird you can sell it it's Capital
but it's weird it's weird for parents to
feel a little scared that God forbid if
a parent has a position a university
that his daughter or son wants to go
into may say no because we found this
clip of you saying this that should not
be the case that is the only part about
this right now with parents where
they're afraid to talk about how they
feel about certain situations where you
go into school in orientation the first
person you hear in orientation is uh I
am part of the lgbtq community I see
myself as a they them or whatever and
I'm this this is that and at our school
we do this this this this that that's
kind of weird to do that if the
population is a small population and
that's who you're trying to Market to
um but anyways you know you see some of
this stuff happening a little awkward
little weird I wanted to kind of share
this book when I saw it I thought other
people would probably relate to the
concerns some parents are going through
you know you know how they say back in
the day when it comes to TV and media
that you got to win the central time
zone
you ever heard that before yes it's not
about
the LA's of the world the New York
cities of the world but like win the
central time zone win Iowa right win
Michigan win Ohio and that's where your
audience is and I feel like there's a
there's a metaphor here to what's going
on here you know what should be
mainstream in America and shouldn't be
contentious or a bad thing to say is
just just normal traditional Family
Values father mother kids happy families
that should be normal
and the the problem to all the the the
the
the Allies to use the word a over there
uh is that you're trying to
basically make this type of stuff
mainstream and you can make that
argument by why this shouldn't be
mainstream but also respect the fact
that you can be who you want to be but
stop indoctrinating kids and that's what
I think essentially your biggest
argument I have I bro again
one day this stuff is going to come out
that when I I mean it's going to come
out what some places I partied at and
what I did I I'm I'm not sitting here
telling you I walk on water I'm not
sitting here if people partied with me
and they asked what was Pat like to
party with some of the stories you're
not going to believe to say Pat really
did that with yes I've had a lot of fun
you know prior to choosing to change my
life I did a lot of stuff in partying in
in in in the military in Tennessee in
Kentucky and Vegas all over the place I
had a lot of fun I've always loved women
and I've had a great time with it but
I've always gotten along with anybody
straight gay whatever I had nicknames
the Greek God because every time I told
him I'm a Syrian they said you're
Sicilian I said forget about it I am
Greek I can't explain to you what a
Syrian is because it was so oh you're
Syrian no Assyrian that four minute of
explanation with a seriousness I got
tired of it yeah well you know what I am
Sicilian you're right I got to know
exact years I got to look I'm Sicilian
let's just finalize right and we're in
the bottom of the boot
so this is not about judgment this is
about leave the kids alone man let the
kids figure out for themselves I had no
idea what I was going to do until many
many years later on in life while I had
a brain to really think and that didn't
happen until many years later this kid
if I if you were to judge me on what I'm
going to do my life in high school at a
1.8 GPA I was a lost cause but it took
me a minute to figure myself out at 25
but a person wants to do that later on
in life let him do it don't put these
things in their mind early you confused
the hell out of a kid when you do that I
got a couple Clips I sent you did you
guys see what Trump said about the
scientists and Florida yesterday okay
Rob if you can play that clip
I want to get your reaction on this uh
this video here go ahead
for those of you
[Music]
there
people are fleeing from New York to
Florida and other places
because of high taxes and out of control
crime it's really bad not because of the
governor thank you Mr President for
doing that
but it's not because of the governor
Florida was doing fantastically you had
a governor named Rick Scott who did a
very good job even Charlie Chris the
Democrat did a good job and he had very
good numbers
sunshine and ocean are very alluring
it's not too hard to work with those
factors
so just remember Florida was doing
really well long before Ron desink just
got there
oh my God okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go to
you I'm gonna go to you first time
it's you know at a time where we need
leadership to rise up versus the
leadership we have in Washington uh I'm
this I've said it before this is going
to be a street fight and this is a guy
that understands media that understands
this base and this is going to be a
street fight and this is just the
beginning that's that's what I think
I've expected this
Adam what are your thoughts yeah Tom's
right this the this is expected look
uh Trump is who Trump is he's not
changing at this point there's still
people out there that think well you
know this time around it's going to be
different
and Trump keep doing what you do and
don't change keep with the nicknames
keep with the name calling it worked for
you in 2016. it may work for you again
in 2024
but watching that I can only tell you
what I felt
it is cringy and it is is childish
just the name calling now as someone
born and raised in Miami I get it I I
the cats out the back Florida's amazing
but to say that uh Ron DeSantis had
nothing to do with how well Florida is
doing currently and during covid
would be just disingenuous and
inaccurate DeSantis Rose to the occasion
and like him or not he kept quote
unquote Florida free and it's it's one
of those situations where yeah Florida
was doing just fine for years and uh you
know uh no tax no income tax state
sunshine and weather and but we do have
issues here we've had hurricanes we have
immigration issues we've got all sorts
of
environmental issues that happen from
time to time but it's it's one of those
things where
is what he did in 2016 going to work
again in 2024 and I've been very clear I
don't think it's going to work this time
around
yeah so so go ahead Tom you can say
Florida was doing well before
but
to disance his credit he was the guy in
the chair when there was some crisis and
he managed him very very well and I set
covet aside on the political side and I
just take a look how he reacted to the
hurricane on the Gulf Coast and I I
think he did a amazing job he pushed
people hard he got that bridge to the
Island rebuilt I mean there's a lot of
things that was just pure leadership of
the crisis team and he deserves credit
for that let me see just one more thing
you know the the whole Trump derangement
syndrome it's a real thing
I know people that
I mean they would not vote for Trump if
I'm like who would you vote for uh
Stalin or Trump they're like oh sign me
up for Joseph Stalin they're not gonna
pick him
um and I I swear I promise you on my
life I'm trying to give Trump a chance
genuinely because we all know that I
haven't been a trump fan I'm genuinely
genuinely let me just keep an open mind
let me see if Trump can win me over and
I think the world has changed so
dramatically
pre-covered to post covet and Tom's
absolutely right we're in desperate need
of leadership of a grown-up in the White
House and I've said the my number one
goal in America right now is to get to a
president who can get to a 60 approval
rating this race to somehow scrape out
50 percent is a race to nowhere and if
the if it's the Santas if it's Nikki
Haley if it's freaking Gavin Newsom not
a fan whoever can get us there is who
I'm leaning towards and I think as of
right now if you look at the top five
people in the polls right now Trump
Biden's still up there Ron DeSantis I
think Ron DeSantis gives America the
best chance for some less divisiveness
so this is all I think I'm going to come
from a place of strategy I'm not going
to come from any other place but just a
place of strategy
uh uh uh Joe Rogan said the other day if
he has to choose between Trump and Biden
it's Trump it's not even a question okay
so that's out there you can go watch the
clip and people lost their minds when he
was saying that he's not choosing Biden
over Trump okay that position has
changed with him over the last however
many years is that the one okay yeah
play that one so the audience can see it
uh yeah play that one just from the
there you go do you have the audio go
for it press play and I go I would vote
for Trump before I'd vote for Biden just
because the thing with Biden like he's
no he's he's gone like you know he's
gone it's you're gonna be relying on his
cabinet and I knew his cabinet would be
this [__] Sideshow of diversity and
which is exactly what it is I mean let
that one person who stole all the
women's clothes that Sam Brinton we
highlighted on the podcast
I mean okay so just real quick note
that's someone who would vocally loudly
vote for Bernie Sanders in 2016. and he
is and I think he voted for Joe
Jorgensen
but now he's back on the Trump trade not
on the train but he's willing to go oh
oh no no he's not on the door willing to
yeah not on the train you know what I
mean he's willing to vote but Biden is
what he's saying right
go ahead but let me let me go back to
what Trump is saying so okay all I ever
think about I got I got my sales leaders
okay and if you've ever been to one of
our sales leadership meetings it's our
one we have a meeting called the
directors and up meaningful president's
Club you have to find a way to get in
there if you're in there it's a
spectacle let me put at you this way
anytime we had our investors or somebody
that wanted to look at purchasing the
company or we're talking about raising
Capital that was a meeting they were not
allowed to go into because if they went
into that meeting they're like what the
hell is going you've been to one of
those meetings before you've been a
couple of insane it's amazing they're
insane it's competitive
it's Insanity it's it's it's like it's
WWE UFC minus any of the fights but it's
raw I wouldn't even say minus any of the
fights because it can get pretty heated
in there I'm trying to keep it PG here
WWE meets Insurance
anyways you got people strutting down
the aisle here
it's epic
and someone who's been in the insurance
industry for 17 years it's my never seen
anything like that before Never Enough
okay it's epic it's competitive it's
awesome right now here's the thing if if
and I'll sit there and I'll watch the
call outs this person calls the other
person out that person calls this person
out it's called I call I call I call a
column yeah and then I'll sit there and
I say yeah that was not a good call out
like what angle did you take
strategically what did you just take
with that angle you went personal okay
that guy
is going to destroy you with what you
just did or this person I'm like that
call out was weak your team you looked
weak in front of your team the worst
type of call outs are when you seem weak
in front of your team for example a call
out is
you'll say well let me tell you
something you guys may be beating us on
the leader's bulletin but at least we
love each other and we're United you
guys are not you're not that is a weak
ass call out okay because you don't want
to compete in your way of hiding it is
what be mommy and your people that
you're working with right here's another
one unmeasurable yeah when you do a call
out and your team's like oh my God my
Leader's an [__] dude what was that
all about you you acted like an [__]
bro dude you had an [__] moment
that's also not a good call out a call
out is to say let me tell you we fell
because of me I screwed up at the end of
the day saw me as the leader but I'm
going to tell you I know what guys we
got and I know our guys are killers
competitors the next 90 days good luck
working out working us out strategy good
luck we're going to compete like never
before and we're going to have one of
the best stories of redemption we're
going to beat you and you're going to
have to eat your warts for what you just
said because our God's gonna rise up
that's a call out where somebody's gonna
say I freaking you know what let's go
kick those guys's ass right this is a
bitter call out
you sound bitter that there's no
strategy behind this to say Florida all
he has to do is to say 34 000 when you
help me and I gave you a shout out in
the book that your two tweets and the
endorsement helped me yes you're right
but I took it from 34 to one and a half
million votes not you that's what I did
right and nobody can dispute that I won
Miami-Dade nobody can dispute that
argument there here's the other part
you know uh with uh Trump and DeSantis
if you read The Art of War Sun Tzu and
you read any of the war books it's very
there's like five of them must read you
have to read if you're a businessman if
you're a businesswoman if you're
somebody that's in a competitive
environment you have to read these books
because if you're not they're reading it
just so you know and I learned this the
heart but I'm like okay no problem you
know for two years I had the same
audiobook playing in my car on repeat
the same exact book every single day for
two years people would get in my car and
my audio was that like this is all you
listen this is all I'm listening what
was the book it's a very good book and I
read it over and over and over again two
years straight in my car on repeat
because I understood it was war and I
saw what my enemy was doing I said I'm
not gonna forget what you did for the
rest of my life this is no longer about
money good luck seeing what you just
gave birth to somebody gonna Facebook
the rest of your life it was officially
personal and was going to get fun let's
go play ball at first it was just about
Dad retiring at first it was just about
having dreams become a reality you
officially pissed me off it's War now
let's go play ball and I'm gonna have so
much fun doing it for 50 freaking years
that was my mindset on this I'll never
forget this by the way fully committed
to war to this one handful of guys that
in the marketplace that were going up
saying certain things
what DeSantis is doing right right now
the book Art of War you know if your
enemy is screwing up get out of his way
and that's exactly what the sentence is
doing he's not even getting in Trump's
way it's like let him keep saying stuff
let him keep saying this stuff his own
Camp was going to turn against him his
own Camp's going to turn against them
because what Trump forgot what Trump
forgot to do is what helped him win as
he talked policies
he talked about make America great again
he talked about the wall he talked about
issues that resonated with people he
talked about that you can easily say
Florida's done a great job with
endorsement because our policies that I
would have used myself that descent you
can say that and the American people
will say I agree with that the centers
use a lot of Trump's policies let's just
say if the voter is going to say this
but when you do something like this it's
showing you're bitter it's showing
insecurity it's showing you fear
somebody that's below you you're
competing with you got to compete up
he's competing down DeSantis as of right
now with the pulse is below you he's not
above you so it's a different strategy
on the way you compete when he was
coming up as an underdog
the way you compete as an underdog can
never be the way you compete as a
favorite I don't know if that makes
sense or not you cannot take the same
strategy as an underdog to compete as a
favorite that's not going to work as a
favorite so and right now in what's the
CPAC Polo was what yeah yeah it's not
even close so and some people say who
cares about CPAC all I'm telling you is
there's a different strategy to compete
as a underdog versus a favorite I don't
necessarily know if this is a effective
strategy he's using again we may be
wrong I may be wrong but I just don't
think it's effective can I ask you one
very specific question because to me it
wasn't the
yeah calling out the Florida thing and
that's all fair game my specific thing
is the the name calling
we all remember 2016 it was uh you know
uh Lil Marco Rubio or slow energy jet or
that was 2020 sleepy Joe or crooked
Hillary or you know everyone had a
little nickname and it was funny it was
weird it was quirky all all that and
above right wacky Bernie all that
the the fact that he's doesn't even call
him Ron DeSantis and it's just Ron de
sancta uh Ron the sancta wrong does a
meatball run is Tom for you as a you
know I would classify you as just like a
level-headed normal just
good father family man does the name
calling do anything for you is it a turn
off you don't like this is something you
don't practice in real life how do you
deal with it when the president is doing
this it does zero for me and I have seen
moments where I thought Trump played so
beautifully the debate with Hillary
Hillary was being very sarcastic and
then made a comment and remember he
turned his back on her and actually she
walked behind him he didn't turn his
back on her he was not disrespectful but
as she rotated the stage she turned
around and pointed at her and rather
than call Naomi said because you'd be in
jail and and basically pulled the rug
right out from under her thing that was
all what America was thinking we were
all at home going there you go you're
gonna play the sarcasm game and you're
gonna do that in a debate Hillary you
just had an adult turn around and and
kind of call you out on that that I
appreciate I because in the Public
Square in politics you have to be
prepared to debate to set your tone own
and you need to have your your comeback
but just sitting there sounding bitter
and calling a name doesn't do anything
for me it doesn't get me it doesn't pull
me in your direction to what you what I
knew you stood for yeah listen we can uh
act very uh what's the word uh Noble and
say oh my God these you know dude
they've been calling this guy a Russian
spy they've called him a racist a bigot
a misogynist give me one label this guy
hasn't gotten the last seven years think
about every single day they've gone
after this guy so so don't get it
twisted I don't like what he said about
the comments on Florida and the fact
that he didn't do anything when you go
give credit to Charlie what are you
doing like he's giving incredible
Charlie Chris what are you like bigger
flip-floppers again out of anybody you
give credit to to give it to Charlie
like to me it's purely that when he says
Ron the sanctu whatever the
sanctimonious meatball that that's his
game plan it's totally fine because the
whole thing is if your opponent gets
irritated by comment keep irritating him
right that's what he's doing he's very
good at it he finds a way to irritate
you and he'll keep doing it and if you
show you're not irritated and eventually
he has to go to a different nickname or
whatever
my concern is in the name Colin my
concern is you can't question someone's
resume that's a real resume it's the
same way when clowns say Trump's not a
real billionaire uh okay you are right
yeah yeah that's right you were able to
go into those you know heavy duty you
know rooms in New York and negotiate
with all these other guys Manhattan to
buy air yeah you're you're definitely a
better businessman than Trump was yeah
you you're the one that carried a show
on NBC for 15 years called what was the
show's name called The Apprentice one of
the greatest and then Shark Tank try to
duplicate that model and the kind of
eyeballs they got Arnold tried to do it
for a season it flopped so bad it was
embarrassing some would say that kind of
finished up his career because you can't
carry a show like that for 15 years no
you can't be Trump trump is not
duplicatable he is very good at what he
does you can't question someone's resume
if it's got true credibility behind it
you make yourself look like a fool and
and here he's trying to question
desantis's resume
what
better
if anybody did it better
he did it better yeah I mean it's not
even a question on on who did it better
he did it better and he you know this is
a chance to come from a place of I'm
glad he used my policies I'm glad he
implemented some of the things that we
were doing and I'm glad he had the
success that he had because he followed
our lead versus
showing signs of
I I I uh I don't see and by the way in
any business book or strategy book I
don't see everything he's done up until
this point like in 2016 when he won
everything was like brilliant
interesting wow crazy risky look at this
guy look
boom he's president holy [__] he pulled
it off and beating who
the person that's supposed to be a
president since she was 10 years old 12
years old she was supposed to be the
first female you beat that heavyweight
whose husband is a president damn okay
cool this guy knows what he's doing but
the biggest feedback is you your
strategy as an underdog will not work as
a favorite it's just not when Michael
was coming up when he wanted to beat the
Lakers for the first time to get the
first ring
and he was talking a lot of [__] yeah
that's a different game when you're
coming back and you lose to the Orlando
Magic because of Nick Anderson whatever
he passes away from Scottie Pippen and
everybody's like he's lost it when
Michael was playing with the number 45.
you remember that yeah of course when
you're Michael coming back after three
Pete everybody's coming for your throat
when you're Michael being beat by
Detroit Pistons and they're bullying you
you're going for everyone's throat you
have a statement to make everybody else
has a statement to make I I don't see
the position here anyways let me go to
the next thing did you guys see a uh uh
you know if I were to ask you right now
as a president if I were to ask you
right now and I was to say
um Tom you're going to be the president
of the United States Adam you're coming
we're sitting down we're having a
conversation Pat I'm thinking about
being the president of the United States
perfect phenomenal what's what do you
think your schedule is going to look
like and at what time you think it
starts if you're the president of the
United States what do you think your
skin you're in Eastern Standard Time
which means California 6 30 9 30 okay 6
o'clock nine three hour difference you
know Europe you got seven hours six hour
difference Middle East Asia you have a
very strange schedule what time do you
think a president should be running his
first meeting
um
there's the answer I think everybody
probably wants to hear but then there's
the real answer if you're going to be
president of the United States you get
to run a four hour sleep and that's
that's the end of it actually Bill
Clinton talked a little bit about this
about how he completely modified his his
sleep but my first meeting
um my first meeting honestly is going to
be 5 6 a.m and my cabinet may not like
it but I'm gonna get my I you know
you've got your threat report that you
get every morning from the CIA
you know threats don't wait they don't
wait till you wake up so you got to go
through that that's always the first
thing there's a folder they give them
called I think it's called the threat
Matrix or something but anyway you you
get that from the CIA it's two to three
pages Max about you know what's moving
around in terms of big threats and then
then man the European markets are open
you know the Asian markets are cruising
and so it's it's time to be up and
digest that and then see what the impact
is going to be on this barometer of the
US economy our markets and so my my
first meeting is is 5 a.m what do you
think
I'm going to get one extra hour of sleep
regardless I'm the president of the
United States here I'm going to sleep
more than four hours but
look at what point Ariana Huffington did
a great um expose on the the the need
for sleep okay and you might
you're the president of the United
States okay even the President should
get more than four hours of sleep every
single night I mean let's not be foolish
yeah now do they get that much sleep I
don't know but I I would say yeah there
it is this Sleep Revolution and she sort
of called out Trump that she thought he
wasn't sleeping let me let me put it if
the president is reading her book I am
worried no he's not let me tell you um
my first meeting would be at six a.m
okay I'd be up at 5 a.m and uh that's
how I would start my day now all I'm
doing is giving one extra hour I think
okay now here's the part who's gonna
know your schedule better than the press
secretary who's gonna know your schedule
better than the press secretary your
wife okay well your wife yeah the butler
that brings you the coffee unless if
you're a guy named Bill maybe it's a
girl named Monica but for the most part
it's your first Secretary yeah you had
to go there but but I want you to see
this morning the way she says it she's
so proud when she says this is Jen saki
right now can you play this clip uh and
that's what people need to hear from him
now it's important to note President
Biden does nothing at 9am he is a night
owl so the fact that he is doing this at
9am anyway speaks to how vital the White
House recognizes it is for him to have
his voice out there in vain that to the
American public
[Music]
it's so committed you know our president
is so committed because he took a 9am
meeting Tom he took a 9 A.M meeting
American people should be thankful
for the prep there's only one position
you set us up with that one Pat 9 A.M
and by the way the wishes can you play
that she's so proud when she said I
think we need to listen to this one more
time watch this just one more time look
how proud she is now it's important to
note President Biden does nothing at 9
A.M
by the way if you're Trump or DeSantis
that's how the ad has got to start go to
exactly President Biden does nothing at
9am you know what I would have a list of
things that happened at 9 00 a.m that
were bad press play we'll need to hear
from him now it's important to know okay
president okay start from right there go
go to exactly where you think he says it
yeah and try to find a time it's
important to know I think it's a little
bit further back let's go back right
there let's try this there's nothing at
9 A.M
anyway speaks to by the way
I don't know any old man that sleeps in
until 9 A.M though most people old
people are up at the crack of dawn
anyway that's that's actually because
your body's kind of programmed I mean
yeah and I would like to know man Ariana
Huffington I'm telling you I I don't
care I don't know how you brought her up
if she was my wife she wrote a great
book on sleep no no no no she was my
wife I guarantee I get an extra five
minutes of sleep a night I'm telling you
the and Biden 9am come on
I guess that was a joke okay there you
go I was like you're here what just
happened no no no my question is he's a
night owl what time's he going to bed I
don't see Biden up till 4am just getting
it in I think he's you know or maybe
they couldn't find it
wandered off do you really put bite in
somebody that goes to sleep at 2 am
no that's what I'm saying I don't I
don't I don't I don't know what's going
on I will say this if you if you're the
enemy if you're if you're China
if you're Russia by the way if you see
that what are you thinking if your enemy
his press secretary says if the
president does a you know this is an
important meeting because president
doesn't do anything at 9am not a good
luck for Joe Budden by the way not to
get all um you know somewhere sad here
that is like we will move the submarines
at 8am no problem this is an article
from the Independent from 2021 that says
that the president begins a short walk
home at 7 pm unlike Mr Obama and Mr
Trump who sat up late into the night
reading briefing documents and watching
right wing cable news respectively Mr
Biden goes to bed relatively early
this this is right so he's not a night
owl rob you just rocked her with what
you just said well and it also says up
here that she uh in the mornings his day
starts at 9 00 a.m when he has coffee
with his wife before he sits down and
takes calls he sleeps for 13 hours
that's insane no way I mean dude like
he's got to write a book sleep 50 of
your day sleep when you're dead
you know what's weird do you remember
what time the first plane hit the World
Trade Center 911 6 30. what's that 6 30
6 30 Pacific Standard Time 9 30 uh
Eastern I thought it was eight something
no
anyway I was at the office so anyway
things happened very early in the
morning okay the first plane to hit the
tower at uh 8 46 a.m okay and then the
second time 46 East 903 yeah okay so
yeah so point is it was right before 9
A.M and then right at 9am and that's
where I was going with this well that's
too much because it's 40 minutes too
early so he's got to tell the next time
somebody wants to attack listen moving
forward you can't attack us three nine
a.m because that's a guideline that's
the president's guideline and he
dictates dictates the terms of War okay
we cannot go to war from 9 pm to 9 A.M
off limits right by the way
this is this is a joke but this is the
funny part it's just not a joke this is
literally sleeping on the job no here's
what I want to know do you think when
she made that comment her phone blew up
afterwards and you're the freaking press
secretary
former what the hell are you saying
why would you say something like that
that is gonna be the perfect ad for
anyone to use against Biden for
2024. she just gave one of the best ads
out there she got a bunch of texts
thanks for the help yeah well what this
this is sort of counterintuitive because
all we hear is that it's sleepy Joe so
it's maybe
[Music]
I'm telling you if there's any stuff
that somebody could say that could
finish your campaign this the statements
like this that this could cause you to
not have a chance at nobody can have a
reputation like this in a Marketplace no
one nobody can have a reputation like
this in the marketplace there's nothing
about this that benefits and strengthens
your country going up against Real
bullies in the world by the way if let's
say it's Trump Biden you know I'm just
I'm already anticipating because they
all have canned lines I'm already
anticipating Trump being like uh you
know you're sleeping on the job type of
thing you know what he's gonna say he's
gonna say you know how he said to
Bloomberg he said uh uh uh when he said
uh you know I don't know why apparently
Bloomberg's been asking about a stool to
make him look taller than I needed to I
don't know why he's asking for it but
I'm here he's going to say something
like look I'm I'm here in Biden's Tom
talking about the fact that 6 PM debate
is a little too late because he's got to
go to sleep that's what I'm here in the
marketplace because he got to go to
sleep and he doesn't do anything before
9 A.M so I mean this just gives an
opening for easy shots to be taken but
but then again Biden can be like listen
Trump I could beat you in my sleep buddy
so don't worry about that so he might
have a can line too it's a pretty bad
one though that is a pretty bad one
let's talk about South Korean government
proposes increase in work week to 69
hours from 52 I'm sure a lot of
Americans uh are wanting America to put
potentially take this idea here we go
this is business life South Korean
government plans to increase
the maximum working hours uh to 69 and
allow for banking overtime in exchange
for time off replacing the 52-hour work
week law introduced in 2018 the new
proposal aims to provide more
flexibility in the labor market
promoting family growth and Improvement
of fertility rate projected Toyota
Global low of 0.7 in 2024 employers and
workers would agree on whether to count
overtime by the week month quarter half
year full year up to 29 hours a week of
overtime allowed for periods a month or
longer over 29 hours of overtime can be
exchanged later for time off of
unspecified raid while the government
argues that allowing workers to spend
accrued overtime on vacations will
enable people who want to work less such
as parents or caregivers to do more to
do so some experts are skeptical about
the proposal's ability to reduce working
hours time what do you think about this
article
um if they're trying to get people to
work longer and solve the fertility rate
I think they got they're trying to burn
that candle at both
I don't think that works I think
somewhere someplace in government the
maximum work week is 69 hours so that
would be if you looked at an American
40-hour week that's 29 hours of overtime
so maybe that's working eight on
Saturday extra five hours every day
that's a lot of overtime
um so I I you know I don't know I
proposed more flexibility in the labor
market it sounds like it's less
flexibility because you're you're
working more and improve the fertility
rate because you're never home I don't
know how that works yeah I agree with
Tom on this I'm did I'm doing the math
on this by the way 69 but this this
seems like a number Elon Musk would make
his employers work like yeah I want you
uh clocking in at 4 20 and you work 69
hours uh a week wink wink
um it seems very Elon muskish but 69
hours divided by five days if that's how
often you choose to work that's 14 hours
a day okay and we all know that you only
to get four hours of sleep these days so
that's that's the number right there's
you only have a certain amount of time
to do your thing 69 divided by six days
is 11 and a half hours if you do the 52
hours a week divided by five that's ten
hours a day I think this is an ongoing
conversation that we continue to have
you know the the work life balance the
four day work week which you just did a
great
um episode on that on valuetainment and
then you know the bigger question do you
live to work or work to live and uh have
you seen the the trending topic on on
Tick Tock these days about this um
it's like uh like Moody Mondays or
something like that I'll find the story
but it's basically like how young people
don't necessarily have to work on
Mondays have you seen that no and I'll
find you this thing
but but you could pull up the fertility
rate I sent you right now countries take
a look at this time lowest in the world
is Taiwan then South Korea Singapore
Macau Hong Kong
I mean top five
all in Asia right oh bare minimum Monday
is what it's called by the way bare
minimum Monday which is what that's the
trending thing on Tick Tock right now
Puerto Rico
I mean how is Puerto Rico so low the
people in Puerto Rico are beautiful like
that should be like 4.8 right
um
British Virgin Island Bosnia Romania
Japan Greece Greece they don't even work
you have all the time to make babies
Poland Portugal Croatia one of the most
beautiful cities on Earth there what
were the stats that we did the other day
about talking about
you said where's the most beautiful
women in the world and you said it
wasn't a city you went to Dubrovnik
Croatia yeah there's no way Croatia is
on that list 1.44
well listen you know when I wasn't
married and I was single my favorite
place to go read books was Croatia
incredible libraries okay so Andorra
Slovakia
hungry these are some low numbers
you know by the way put the highest
fertility rate flip it let's see what
the highest fertility these are for the
lowest fertility lowest not having kids
not having kids all right not having
kids
uh is it in Mexico
highest fertility rate
by countries what wow 6.9 wow makes
sense
go a lot of is in Africa zooming yeah
Somalia 6.0
all Africa yeah it's all Africa well
when you have no economy you have time
on your hand look at this South Korea
the lowest fertility rates there it is
that's why they're implementing this so
so can you can you go back to see if the
list goes even higher like what they
need is a lot of Africa
they had a lockdown Tom no no not this
one that only shows top 10 that's where
you are go to another one to see if we
can go even lower
yeah like I want to see more than just
10. no this one's only going to give you
a few
what's the highest
zoom in see if we see anything
uh Somali one would keep going lower
keep going lower in Afghanistan 4.72
Sudan Zambia Cameroon yeah I mean that's
pretty wild to be at 0.9
so I don't I don't understand the
correlation with the amount of hours you
work do you know why
I mean dude I don't know how many people
like work you know like I work I got
four kids like you mean to tell me you
don't have time to make babies
wow well the more you work the less time
for leisure
so that that is that is that doesn't
make any sense you know why that doesn't
make any sense okay Greece is known as
the lowest of working hours one of the
lowest working hours in the country they
don't work that many hours they're not
even making kids so the correlation to
me doesn't make any sense well go back
to that thing about South Korea they're
the lowest infertility yet they want to
increase
the working
right I just pulled up this article
Psychology today why does South Korea
have the lowest fertility rate in the
world okay it says the vast majority of
young couples in South Korea end up
having one child because of high child
car child care costs young couples also
have delay having children because of
expensive housing to increase fertility
rate South Korean government should
Implement long-term plans to reduce
Child Care and housing costs okay so
that's the reason why there's there's
been more affordable to have a family
there's no way it's because you don't
have time there's no way you don't have
time I mean how many go to the Fortune
500 company CEOs how do they have all
these kids well they got money housing
and uh but their work is not a concern
it's it's yeah exactly so it's got
nothing to do with the number of hours
you work why do soldiers have so many
kids
you know it has to do with money it has
to do with other than it's not just
about you don't have time it doesn't
take 22 hours to have sex
I mean it's it it's a if you do I mean
it's respect
good job can you imagine like yeah no
that he he definitely wasn't a 22 hour
guy who hit us twenty thousand numbers
he was more like a two-minute guy yeah
hit it and quitter he's out he had like
20 000 is a tough number to get
McDonald's drive through Manny I think
interesting here here I like where you
went with this Pat by the way I'm
focusing more on the work component
you're the more focused on the fertility
it comes down to money FTM follow the
money that's what it comes down to huh
it comes down to money and culturally
what you're saying okay religion culture
like I don't know the philosophies of
what what they what they're teaching
from the top whatever the influence at
the top is saying they're gonna do okay
whatever you know how we looked at the
Muslim Church Muslim denomination how
many kids they're having versus
Christians yeah it's not even close it
comes from the top whatever they're
saying at the top they're doing Mormons
what are Mormons known for what's the
joke about Mormons they got 20 wives
yeah and not not the wives part but
that's the first place you go to oh yeah
I don't know where were you going like a
fantasy for you
somebody has six kids what do they say
you must be a more oh yeah right because
they from the top they're having a lot
of kids this has got nothing to do my
opinion I don't think the primary factor
is so uh I think it's other other things
not the number of hours they're working
per week but it's a good good way to
spin it if people want to spin it let's
go to the next story Iran and Saudi
Arabia signal the start of New Era with
China front and center this this title
just doesn't sound good period for
America
uh Saudi Arabia and Iran have agreed to
re-establish diplomatic relations making
marking a major shift in their
decade-long rivalry that has defined the
middle east region the two countries had
been in talks for nearly two years and
their diplomatic breakthrough was
unexpected yet not surprising China
played a key role in the negotiations
highlighting its growing influence
in the oil-rich region which may have
repercussions for U.S influence in the
region the announcement could Herald the
end of a long-standing era of conflict
in the Middle East the debtny goes far
beyond the resumption of diplomatic
relations and Saudi Iranian officials
will work to revive old security
cooperations and technology and trade
agreements Tom thoughts on this one here
this is a CNN Story by the way there is
one thing that China needs more than
anything else long term that is energy
we all know that's the one thing that
they don't have uh natural resources to
support and so they need energy deals
and they've been out cutting energy
deals that's point one point two is
China always plays the long long game
not just the long game the long long
game and they're looking at strategic
they've been looking at you know the
whole Silk Road initiative and a path to
the Middle East you know originally
through Afghanistan
and this is them making friendships in a
region getting their hands on long-term
energy contracts in extending their
influence on a world stage with people
who you know in one way you know Iran is
a bit of an orphan who needs some
friends Saudi Arabia isn't really
they're more of opportunists but this is
China playing a long game and uh getting
energy in their pocket yeah I gotta tell
you I did not see this coming whatsoever
I mean if you know anything about the
Arab world it essentially breaks down to
Sunni and Shia right and Iran is the
number one Shiite country in the world I
want to say and Saudi Arabia is the
mecca literally of uh Sunni Muslims and
I I thought I was under the impression
that they were mortal enemies that was
my assumption and to see that China
is at the center of diplomatic relations
between Sunni and Shiites Muslims is
wild to me and I'm wondering where's the
US in this what role Israel playing in
this we've seen that uh prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu
not so subtly referenced the fact that
he's been working with Saudi Arabia and
other Arab countries and he's kind of
said as making peace with the 99 of the
Muslim world before he gets to the one
percent which is the Palestinian
situation in Gaza and the West Bank and
I'm wondering what this type of
relationship with Saudi Arabia and Iran
even looks like
um what type of diplomatic relations
will come from this what China's actual
role will be and again where's the
United States in this situation because
I mean you grew up in Iran you know you
the government is constantly saying
death the United States that the United
States but the people tell a different
story there and uh Saudi Arabia is quote
unquote wink wink our Ally and uh I mean
I think we provide them with a vast
majority of their weaponry and uh I
don't know is this a good thing for the
world that Saudi Arabia and Iran are
resuming diplomatic relation a good
thing Rob go go on Google if the average
person wanted to go search the following
Iran's number one enemy like if you want
to find that Iran's worst enemies in the
Middle East how would you search it what
would you type Iran's enemies yeah okay
worst enemies okay go on that let's see
what comes up okay Israel Saudi Arabia
if you go right there which countries to
the enemies of Iran yeah if you go
you'll see Saudi Arabia is like on at
the top of the list in the middle of the
picture it's at the top of the list
right so so here's the point these guys
until now okay until now uh with the
help of China so
if during your reign
your enemies unify together
you officially became the worst enemy
America's ever had
so let me let me unpack that right there
if a leader if a leader you know when
when years ago we were had just started
our insurance company
and competitors of ours uh eventually
Ward got out which was awesome because
they would call me and tell me this and
they would say the following a guy
wanted to leave one of our competitors
and in that company they would say we
will leave you alone and not Sue you if
you go to any company except for one
company
and you cannot go to PHP with Pat you
can go anywhere but you can't go there
okay
so those people would call me and they
would say can I have a call with you can
I ask you why they're saying this
they said to me I can't go anywhere but
I cannot join you why is that I said why
do you think
I don't need to tell you why do you
think well I don't know I I it's now
everybody is asking why do they want us
to go anywhere they won't do anything to
us but if we go to you we're going to
sue you
okay so guess what what do you say to
that
is that a good strategy is that a bad
strategy you got to give credit they're
better off not me
you know them unifying with me as an
enemy okay
because your opponent is getting what
stronger and stronger and stronger they
were taking the right position credit to
them as a competitor
but think about it if all of a sudden
all your enemies that are leaving you
under your Reign they all choose to
unite
they hated each other a year ago they
hated each other five years ago not
their best friends yeah how does that
happen in life there's cause and effect
what caused it this is the effect what's
the cause is it the cause of the way a
president handled Ukraine and Russia
conflict is is it the cause of how Biden
handled his foreign affairs is that the
cause when is the last time you've heard
China Russia Iran and Saudi Arabia now
being best friends yeah certainly not
Saudi the rest of them yes you add that
to the list what kind of power now do
they have the amount of power they have
now is multi-dimensional they got oil
scored away
they got manufacturing scored away
they got nuclear bombs scored away they
got a lot of things scored away they
definitely got land scored away and so
now it's going to be what it's not going
to be EU and us
and then you have China Russia Iran
Saudi
and then they're going into Africa China
is because they're going out there and
buying all those you know
the land to help them with their you
know batteries and lithium and all
Cobalt and all the stuff that they're
they're the Silk Road they're being so
strategic themselves okay you got to
give them credit strategically China's
out strategizing U.S today and U.S keep
sending more and more money to zielinski
and zielinski has so much control now
over the U.S where he has the audacity
to say to say if the war gets worse
American parents will be losing their
sons in war because they're gonna have
to send their sons I'm prefacing what he
said he's saying that American kids are
going to have to go to war who the hell
are you to make a comment like that but
here's the part what did the U.S
president say nothing
if zielinski makes a comment like that
and the US government doesn't say
anything about it have you seen this
video or no when he says this yeah you
can uh U.S will have to send troops to
fight in Ukraine who the hell are you to
say U.S will have to send troops to
fight the war in Ukraine like I'm sorry
are you officially the president of the
United States or are you the president
of Ukraine
you're not responsible for our kids and
what they're going to be doing but the
fear tactic works on what he's doing so
this is all that's the one I think right
there zoom in a little bit to see if
this is the one does he say it in
English or is it translated plate
let's see what
the U.S will have to send their sons and
daughters exactly the same way as we are
sending their sons and daughters to war
and they will have to fight because who
are you nature that we're talking about
I'm sorry we'll be dying God forbid
because what a horrible thing do you
realize what like you're speaking on
behalf of our kids
who the hell are you to even have the
audacity to talk like that
do you understand what I'm do you
understand like the the the rage to have
a guy we're sending you money you're
talking like you are like our president
reports to you the other day ESPN came
out and apologized yesterday for
comments made by uh Kendrick Perkins and
the girl from First Take what's her name
Molly Molly comes out and Molly says
there were certain comments made here
about the fact that 80 of MBA voters who
vote for MVP are white those stats are
not true and not only not true they're
drastically wrong and we just wanted to
correct that her words okay to to check
who ESPN has to set downstairs Kendrick
you can't say stuff like that yeah you
were wrong right you were wrong you know
if you know if somebody like that says
it under your Administration you and I
are talking and this guy says something
like this guess what you have to say the
next day you have to say we understand
the pressure
president zielinski is under but with
all due respect President zielinski we
decide when we send our sons and
daughters to war not you we that is our
responsibility I understand you're
losing a lot of loved ones and a lot of
kids you don't get to make a comment
like that that guy's gonna get a phone
call from me five minutes after he make
it makes a comment like that but I
totally agree that's if you're the
president I agree with you and I'm very
incensed by the comment but what I was
asking myself when I heard it was why
does that guy think it's okay to say
that
who is giving him the impression in any
way at any time that it's okay to say
that is he just outside of his mind is
he just have big cojones why why would
he think it's okay to say that who's
given him that impression that it's okay
to say that because if you're the leader
he doesn't even say that I don't think
but also by the way
if you saw the end of the clip he said
because NATO would have to step in and
one would say all right there is an
agreement with the NATO coordinator but
they're not part of NATO even that's
correct Ukraine is not part of NATO it's
one of the seven excuses that started
this thing exactly so that's the whole
justification for this this Invasion so
if a NATO country says something like
that what is that called like Amendment
two or whatever whatever the number it
is within the NATO Clause would you
attack one country we all must defend
her so whatever number it is right
um if a NATO country says that okay
that's part of the agreement but you're
not part of NATO correct so there's a
sort of an entitlement situation that I
think is happening it's one of us is all
of us right what is that what is that
NATO provision right there Rob I don't
know if you want to go with that real
quick but back to the China
Saudi Iran situation you know how they
say what the the uh the enemy of the
enemy is my friend
there just seems to be uh well that
situation going on here all of that
happened under his reign
all of that happened under Biden
Article 5 of NATO that's what all of
that happened under Biden unifying the
enemies
you get to take that with your legacy
with you you strengthen our enemies and
brought them together congratulations uh
congratulations
Saudi under his watch watch what's
happened under his watch you unified the
enemies
we lost our weapons in Afghanistan okay
uh a bank or two went out went under
okay this is all under your watch is
what's going on this is all under your
watch and if you go to Prior
Administrations
no banks under Trump
these issues weren't happening and in uh
China Iran is any of that stuff and you
were not having those issues with
Afghanistan and that comes down to
management it comes down to leadership I
know nobody wants to hear this but you
have to be able to set it aside and
realize these are not good things those
guys those four getting together doesn't
help American if you're watching this
right now yourself and you're saying wow
can't believe you're saying this you're
only you're like a spokesperson for you
know such and such and this is what you
are I can't believe you're saying this
Pat no no
think about your kids don't think about
your arguments that you've had to defend
because of your mom dad or Professor or
teacher or whoever
actually think about it what happens
if you're a gang in the streets
and four other of the biggest gangs who
hated each other and killed each other
they joined forces
what happened to your community did you
get safer is it safer for your kids if
you can still sit there and say I'm
gonna be okay no problem
but if you sit there and say this is not
good yeah then next time around think
before sitting there and saying I just
don't want to get that guy out there
because I don't like the way DeSantis or
Trump or this guy the way they talk it's
they don't seem like they're gentle
leaders yeah you definitely don't want
your leaders to be gentle towards the
enemy yeah I look at it this way there
are players in every major sport that
would rather work for a soft coach and
cash the check they don't have a burning
desire to go win championships they'd
like to win a championship but they'd
really rather have the easy check the
soft coach and a good city and then you
have people that want to work for an
easy boss a soft boss and work from home
and have it easy well let me tell you
when it comes to your country and it
comes to World stage you don't have that
option that is not an option that's
available and I will forever remember
Trump's handshake with Putin I remember
what I'm talking about Pat where he
pulls him in tight it's like what are
you doing dude you know and I will
remember how he made the Chinese nervous
on trade I remember how he sat there and
told the German representatives in NATO
you got to pay your fair share let me
tell you you may not like it and it may
not be the guy you want to work for or a
coach you want to play for but that's
not the way this works when it's your
country tree and that's not the world
stage that we live on now and that's not
the reality of life we have you have to
have solid leadership and under Biden's
watch these things have happened and
they're not good here it is I love this
you see a little tug there Pat you know
what that means
that's his move
Pompeo Kushner
it's it's uh there are messages in there
now of course there's a message and I'm
just saying for me in every situation
like this uh you can't you have to draw
the line and not let people do certain
things and that's unfortunately happened
let me go to a golden sacks just said
yesterday Tom Goldman Sachs says no
longer expects the FED to hike rates in
March
City stress on banking system this is a
CNBC story that just came out uh a a uh
this comes out after regulations
announces measures to prevent the spread
of contagion following the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank and the culture of
Signature Bank citing system systemic
risk in the light in light of distress
in a banking system we no longer expect
the fomc to deliver a rate hike as its
next meeting on March 22nd said Goldman
Economist uh John hatsu's on a Sunday
Noel Goldman has previously anticipated
a 25 basis point hike last month to rate
Federal Reserve opened
Federal Open Market Committee increased
the federal funds rate by a quarter of a
percentage point to a target range of
4.5 to 4.75 its highest since 2007 the
bank still expects to see 25 basis point
hike in May June and July with a
terminal rate expected to be at 5.25255
what do you think Tom is he going to
increase it or is it going to stay flat
and not do anything for a minute first
of all I gotta remember who's talking
here Goldman Sachs is talking who's
hasn't had the best of quarters has been
laying off people and there's even been
uh you know some very carefully written
articles talking about David Solomon but
Goldman said this on Sunday Goldman is
lobbying to go back lower because it
helps the banking industry it helps him
get cheaper money
um that's what they're begging for and
by the way Goldman is the same guys that
worked with Silicon Valley Bank you know
from uh two weeks ago and couldn't get
the deals done and couldn't get all that
put together so this is Goldman I think
just just kind of out there you know you
know curfing for moisture just trying to
you know grab a little bit and and and
Lobby uh the other banks that are out
there saying hey given a little
uncertainty we think 50 basis points off
the table probably just be 25. I think
that's we're going to see but this was
Goldman on Sunday lobbying and hoping in
my opinion and and they're in a weak
position they haven't had a good couple
quarters as you've seen I guess my
question is you know you got Goldman
saying some things you got Barclays
saying some things you got the bond King
Jeffrey gun like saying some things
everyone's going to give their opinion
on this
is Jerome Powell going to be swayed by
anybody
Jerome Pyle is on a mission right now to
bring down inflation he's fighting that
with the interest rates obviously
unemployment's also a factor uh
Jerome Powell he's been battle tested
he's been through multiple
administrations at this point
um
is he going to continue the course with
these uh rate increases is he going to
stand Pat as as the bond King Jeffrey
gunlock kind of pointed out
um that that remains to be seen like it
is a bank failure or multiple bank
failures like this enough to
um
diverge his his expedition of of
increasing rates he's done a pretty good
job of saying sort of uh agnostic to
what the presidents have to say and what
banks have to say you saw that his uh
interaction with what was that Senator
Kennedy Kennedy uh the other day in
Louisiana yeah Louisiana when he he gave
him a little breakdown right there of
all the interest rate situations I'm not
picking on you I just want an answer
I'm cotton pick an answer so but gonna
like the bond kick said the following is
to save the central bank's credibility
they will probably raise rates 25 basis
points I would think uh uh that the I
would think that that would be the last
increase he gunlock does not think that
the Federal Reserve is going to slow
down because of this there's there's a
lot of different uh perspectives here
there's Goldman saying one thing there's
gun like saying one thing there's
Bloomberg saying one thing Bloomberg
says feders of Jerome Powell uh plans to
raise interest rates at a faster uh Pace
to curb inflation has been disrupted by
the collapse of Silicon Valley banking
signature which has cost Financial
instability meaning they're saying that
he may not now is this a indirect way of
Bloomberg and Goldman trying to talk to
Powell to get him to say don't do it by
putting fear in there who knows
yesterday Megan Kelly hosted a debate I
don't know if you
was on there with David sacks
everywhere right it was a very very good
debate and Vivek didn't back down about
his argument and they actually went at
it it was a very good position both of
them presented a very good argument
Vivek said you went out there and you
put so much fear that they finally said
fine here's what we're going to be doing
we're going to do a backstop and bail
out the customers and he's saying that
is still the wrong move and David is
saying you're being irresponsible to
think what you're thinking I'm thinking
about more the people and then Vivek
said these are people that you know they
have they're not the small time business
owners they're the bigger ones it's not
just a small and middle income guys that
are being hit the point is we don't
really know what Powell's going to be
doing I I don't know if Powell's the
type of guy that is super predictable
where he's going to I think he is a
sensible guy that he can be convinced
but he also has a backbone meaning which
is exactly placed to be I put him a high
score for being able to reason in this
specific context I see him hearing out
from everybody that calls him and saying
hey
they probably have a list you know they
probably have a list of banks that are
next can you pull up the the list of
banks that are next uh uh just put like
the next Silicon Valley Banks who's on
the list of the next Silicon Valley Bank
whatever if you search it it'll come up
they have a list of banks that they're
looking at and they know where they're
at because they have many of these guys
have to report their names
and the more these lists become public
lists okay meaning if there's new names
that pop up think about what you're
thinking if you have your money in that
bank
you do not want to be on any list right
now by any credible Source at first you
understand what I'm saying so so isn't
the list to be on no so imagine the call
being made to Jerome to say hey uh
Jerome here's what you need to know
if you increase the rates you will
officially be the First Federal Reserve
chair to have seven backs go under do
you want that part of your legacy
let me say this one more time Jerome
Powell if you raise rates quickly like
you've been doing there's another seven
banks that are like Silicon Valley Bank
that are going to get hit and they're in
the top 38 and they're 100 billion
dollar Banks do you want that part of
your legacy and Jerome has to really
think about that
he really has to think about this
especially when you look at FDIC and
FDIC he's got how much money 125 billion
can you look at how much FDIC has right
now
if you go look at how much FDIC is right
now I saw a number the other day 35
billion as of yesterday or something
like that how much does what what do
they have okay this as of 2022 but do
they have the number as of 2023 okay so
they have 128 billion
uh uh give or take to cover one point
1.26 of a total 9.9
trillion so that's not billion trillion
right so I do think Jerome has to think
about his next move and how quickly
increases rates I do think he has to
think about that because he will could
potentially that the fear that the
opposing side could put on him as you
will be known as the the chair where the
most banks went under under your
leadership I don't know if he wants that
and I don't even know if that even does
anything to his decision-making process
well we talked about yesterday we had a
guest on yesterday who talked about that
he thought with the new uh depositor
protective in place that protects
against the bank run because everybody
can calm down there and say you don't
have to run the bank if something ever
happened to your bank you know there's
going to be a backstop from the federal
government and this 25 billion dollar
fund that's been set up and I said I
thought there was a 25 chance of of it
happening and specifically I meant you
know First Republic because there are
and I characterize them yesterday as I
do now as they're kind of hopping on one
leg
um and and that's where it's that's
where it's going to go so
I and I I'm not changed from yesterday
even though I read a ton of stuff early
this morning pbd
if there's ongoing Jitters which really
seem to be calming pretty quick in
banking I think he backs off the 50
because he doesn't want to Jitter the
system but he's going to keep going
after inflation and I don't think it has
to do it's really interesting the
central bank's credibility what do you
mean credibility this is not a thing
where you say I did what I said I was
going to do no things happen the economy
moves around we just saw over the
weekend a lot of things happened
sometimes pretty damn quick and so I
think he looks at it and says is
everything calmed down enough are we
going to Spook the system no okay well
then I'm continuing with 0.25 because we
got to continue this March against
inflation and I think he's got a
backbone I thought he looked pretty
impressive we were making fun of Kennedy
and I'm sorry that anybody was offended
by me using that voice but I thought
Trump Powell handled himself pretty well
and pretty stable I think so at that
hearing oh yeah by the way I just Paul
Rob just did a quick poll 97 of the
audience was offended by the way you
yeah
condescending approach towards the
candidate you know oh good afternoon let
me buy everybody a nice red flesh let me
let me read a super chat here by Paul
which which is kind of interesting so
shout out to Paul uh uh Powell will
continue to raise rates stress testing
the vulnerable ones then bail them out I
mean backstops short up the bank making
them even more powerful As Americans get
crushed and loose okay powerful or
powerful well there's a play on words
yeah I like that powerful but you know
he's saying powerful by the way there's
a part of what he's saying that he's got
a very good point because think about it
this way
if if you know the establishment and if
you know if these guys truly want to
eliminate smaller Banks and to make this
thing even more nationalized this is
where I do it it's centralized banking
if if that is truly the agenda hey
Jerome Powell if you really want to do
that don't raise it by quarter don't do
half go three quarters of a basis point
if this guy goes half of 100 if he goes
half or higher then there's a community
of people that will say I think they
kind of do want to get rid of smaller
Banks and bring them together I don't
know Paul if I'm there where you are
right now but if it does happen
uh there's an argument for that for sure
because it is strengthening the top four
or five banks that uh they would sit
there and say big thank you I'm sure if
uh Powell raised the rates anything half
or higher he may get a nice bottle of uh
wine and some nice cigars from the top
five banks in America saying hey right
you're amazing well I just got a text
from Jamie Diamond
um we're up for three quarters of a
point my boys are ready hell
oh my I just got a text from Senator
Kennedy in Louisiana he's got his uh
he's got his eye on you there Biz dog oh
no not happy with your impersonation
we'll go up for I'll buy him a nice
redfish dinner down there it's delicious
oh that's appropriating uh Cajun culture
no so if you're down there in Louisiana
you can get it fresh and it's delicious
it's fantastic let's talk about building
a brand new beans and rice let's talk
about building a community which is what
Elon Musk is doing Elon Musk bought us
out to make a tiny village
for his workers Elon Musk has spent
Millions purchasing land in a small
Texas neighborhood in Bastrop outside of
Austin City Limits to build his own
little village near Tesla SpaceX and
boring companies musk's vision is to
create his own Utopia where his
employees can live and work some of the
locals have already sold their land to
musk but while they were initially told
it would be the use for workers housing
they learned later that musk plan to
build a town however must call The Wall
Street Journal report that he is
building a town false on Friday the idea
of living in an unregulated private town
or city has risen in popularity in
recent years and Praxis is one of the
newer projects funded partially by Peter
Thiel the goal is to build a city
outside the United States and free of
government control there's interest for
that I have a question for you go ahead
anytime you use that sarcastic slow
voice you have a strong opinion on
something like that so tell me Patrick
why did you read it in that tone what
are you feeling like
you know I I just like that he's toying
with people I love it I love the fact
that he's toying with people and messing
with people and just getting them to
constantly talk about what he's up to
but by the way if he's doing this what's
wrong with it say he is doing this and
say you work for Tesla and say you asked
for it you know we have some guys here
that you know we were about to make that
offer on that 11 acre land that we were
looking at you know what a lot of people
ask for can we build some boxable homes
there yeah can we get five or ten
boxable homes where we can rent the idea
of wanting to build a community is not
far-fetched or anything there's a lot of
other people that wish
that wish they had the kind of a culture
where the people would want to build a
community yeah that's called you're
making great cultures not by force it's
by choice you don't have to live there
it's purely a choice and a benefit and
an add-on so whether he's doing this or
whether he's not doing this there's no
difference between what he is doing or
what Disney World did in Orlando when
Walt Disney was using other people's
names to buy a plan because they didn't
want to sell it to him directly and then
all of a sudden they're like holy [__]
this guy bought up all the land and he
built his own ZIP code or two or three
called Disney World elon's just building
his own Disney World shout out to him by
the way I'm all about the company
culture and when you were gonna maybe
make that 13 million dollar offer on
that 40 million dollar condo in downtown
Miami at the Thousand Biscayne Museum
the Hadid building I was willing to
sacrifice my lifestyle to live in that
ridiculous Penthouse University
from your end so if that's what you want
to build if you want to build that
community that small village in down
downtown Miami and you need a team
leader yeah just sign me up Pat the the
you're like a great uh uh War buddy
willing to go above and beyond and
sacrifice yourself I was just gonna say
it comes down to sacrifice Pat and I'm
willing to sacrifice what I'm doing
right now it's an emotional to live in
the penthouse
team ChapStick and you are kissing some
major butt at the moment no he he by the
way he knows how much I love Heights and
the balcony like what I would do is
every night we'd have dinner in the
balcony that's what we would be doing
every night so let's go to this Colin
Kaepernick story here Colin Kaepernick
accuses white adoptive parents of
problematic upbringing perpetuating
racism
this this is not a a joke by the way
this is actually what he said okay
so
uh Colin Kaepernick formal NFL star and
activist used his white adoptive parents
of perpetuating racism in a new
interview in his upcoming graphic novel
changed the game Kaepernick spoke about
growing up in a problematic household
and how his parents tried to steer him
in a Direction they thought was best
which led to several fights between them
and their adopted son one of those
discriments Illustrated in the novel was
a fight over his hairstyle Kaepernick
wanted to wear cornrows but his mother
pushed back a legend saying oh your hair
is not professional oh you look like a
little Thug the lack of racial Harmony
in his home uh own home encouraged
Kaepernick to find Community elsewhere
and he chose to pursue a football career
instead of a professional baseball
career because they were significantly
more blacks in the NFL and MLB
Kaepernick still hopes to return to the
NFL and has worked as an activist and
advocate for social justice issues I I
have like so many different issues
issues with this article here but I'll
go to you first man go ahead I just
so if you're Colin Kaepernick you're
adopted
by
what is where's pants white what were
they yeah if you can pull up okay the
the Colin Kaepernick's sales
if someone adopts you
I assume they take you out of a foster
care
or of a situation that you probably
don't want to be in so this family
adopts Colin Kaepernick
and now he resents the fact that they
adopted him because they're saying hey
if you do certain things people are
going to judge you you know what's crazy
I actually had a conversation yesterday
randomly with uh our friend Jerry who
works upstairs in the sales department
black guy right and he's sitting there
with April another black woman great
great Duo if they're watching shout out
to them and he literally just put
cornrows in his hair did you see it I go
oh hey nice new hairdo he goes yeah man
I've been wanting to do this like for
years
but my family were I believe their
Seventh-Day Advent uh Venice at Venice
and he goes see this this is very much
frowned upon I said oh okay tell me why
he goes yeah you know cornrows
tattoos this is something you just can't
do and he's a black guy I go all right
explain how he's like it just it's just
frowned upon he's he's explaining to me
why all right cool got it so this isn't
a race thing this is a culture thing
right and so for instance it'd be the
equivalent of a white guy just growing
as long hair out and listening to heavy
metal and his parents saying hey if you
actually want to be taken seriously you
probably can't just
you know look like Axel Rose out there
or slash just with hair flowing if you
want to actually be taken seriously like
that so wouldn't you agree that your
parents probably your adoptive parents
want the best for you
it would just seem that Colin Kaepernick
has sort of Lost
Common Sense Tom
I I would feel different than I do right
now if over the course of the last 10
years
you've been hearing him say I only
played football because I thought there
was more racial diversity in the sport
uh I didn't hear that I didn't hear that
and no we heard a lot about Colin uh Kim
and I saw him in the airport by himself
not very famous
um
and he was very chill and I don't
remember comments made like that and he
maybe he can say he's repressed and all
that but to suddenly come out and I also
didn't remember him saying you know you
know I've lived in a repressed household
I just feel like you know each step he
has to appropriate some other offense to
continue to
you know presses relevance and he is
relevance he brought attention to some
things
um some in the right way some in the
wrong way and some were positive some
not I'm just kind of shocked now that
now it's time to you know go attack a
bunch of other things and I haven't
heard that his parents were these tough
people they adopted him you know
adoption is an act of Charity you know
they owe him respect as he grows up just
as he owes them respect it's called
family let me tell you man I have so
many problems with this uh first of all
his biological mother Heidi I believe
Russo gave him up at five weeks okay
until today the biological father they
don't know who it is it's unknown okay
so if it's unknown I mean I don't want
to get graphic but you understand what
that means yeah the only way somebody's
unknown is because
you know you had a lot of different
partners she was very friendly let's
just say yeah so okay so so let's let's
put the perspective then there's the
adopted parent the parents that adopted
you so there's four people in this
in this situation here for you to
recognize and not recognize till 2021 he
didn't want to meet his mother his
biological mother
for giving up for adoption you have your
father who you don't know who he is you
have your biological mother
who you don't want to meet then you have
the parents that adopted you and you
think you made it into the NFL
let me get this straight you think you
made it to the NFL all on your own
seriously
do you think you did that
I I'm sorry you know the the role that
parents play to buy the uniforms to take
you to practice to be part of leagues
and drive you an hour or fly you out and
bring coaches and do you know how many
thousands of hours his parents or mother
sacrifice
and this is what you say just to sell a
story in a documentary it's a slap on a
face to parents do you know what this
does to people that are considering to
adopt this is the fear of parents that
are afraid to adapt you mean you want
parents to put 15 20 years of their
lives into adopting a kid and 20 years
later they get something like this
because now you have money you don't
need them anymore
it's the ultimate insult it's
um disgusting if you ask me there's no
parent that is perfect but anybody that
chooses to adopt you give you a home
take care of you and now you have this
kind of a life because of what they did
to sacrifice thousands of hours there's
nobody in the world there's there's two
people in the list of your life
that you should never be able to
criticize and it's the two parents that
adopted you those two people you need to
lift up and turn them into Heroes
forever you cannot say anything about
those two specifically in an
embarrassing way like this
adoption is a choice anyways and those
parents did not care what color you were
yeah and they adopted you respect
respect to uh respect to his parents for
what they did and uh it is what it is I
remember watching the Super Bowl with
this kind of game I couldn't believe the
stuff he was doing I really enjoyed
watching the Super Bowl it's a great
game yeah anyway okay we're at the end
of the we're at the end of the podcast
we're a minute over we got some stuff to
do I do want to say a couple things here
guys uh we're getting a lot of requests
from different people when entrepreneurs
that were uh having conversations with
about uh anxiety about mental and
emotional challenges some people that
are going through the right now with
businesses so I am hosting a webinar
specifically for that topic on March
28th at 6 00 PM Eastern Standard time
we're going to talk about hardship
currently going on dealing with
pressures on how to thrive during
turbulent times this is if you're trying
to figure out a way on how to be
mentally and emotionally tougher in a
strange time like this this is the
webinar for you specifically for those
who are are in competitive environments
you're running a business you're an
entrepreneur you're a thriving person
that's moving up and you got a lot of
different pressures you're a parent your
father your mother you're trying to do a
lot at the same time and get the
finances in order this webinar is for
you the link will be in the description
below again March 28 6 p.m Eastern
Standard Time go and register for it and
put it in your calendar so we can spend
an hour together on March 28th 6 p.m
Eastern Standard Time Rob do you have
the link or have they send the link to
you not yet but I'll get it and put it
in let's get the link let's put in the
chat uh Mario Kai if you're listening to
the send it to rap so Rob Hazard to put
in the description gank have a great day
uh we will do this again I think
Thursday with a guest so we'll see you
Thursday with the guests this week take
care everybody